- How many of you are
asking me what I'm gonna do when
I hit a million
followers on Instagram?
Nothing.
Haven't even
been paying attention.
I don't give a fuck.
Sorry.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
(upbeat music)
Yeah, doing that.
Hi.
There needs to be an FBC.
Facebook commercials.
You have to stop playing,
we had an incredible meeting.
Punchline is I've done a lot of
things over the last eight weeks
to not only, I think get the
organization here to at least,
I think that all
hands on was like this.
And then the changes this week.
But I've got (censored) more
excited about making it a bigger
thing than they did before.
- [Steve] Yeah.
- And if they put time,
money and resources behind it,
it will be a thing.
- [Steve] And I'm Steve Babcock.
I'm the Chief Credit Officer
at VaynerMedia and
I've been here for 10 months.
10 whopping months.
It's been really, really
good in that it's been really
challenging but in
a good way, I think.
It wasn't built with
the emphasis on that thing.
It was built on the
placement of that thing.
Really good
understanding of the platforms,
understanding behaviors,
understanding the tricks,
the hacks, all these great
things such an efficient place
for performance marketing
through the social channels.
I got really excited about
the opportunity to come in and
hopefully influence and
add that layer of emphasis
on the creative product.
- [Gary] I still
want you filled in.
We need to go fast.
So it'll be amazing if she goes
ahead and buys something
but it's not on her.
- Yeah, a little bit of
black coffee, please.
- A little black coffee? Cool.
- [Linda] Hi, sweetheart.
- Wow, does Reeves look
unbelievable in
the holiday card.
- Thank you.
- Wow.
- Your's are gorgeous.
- Thank you.
- Gorgeous, gorgeous.
Really fun.
- Yeah, I like it.
How great is this view, huh?
- [Linda] I started boxing.
- What?
That's so crazy.
That's what I'm
gonna do with my next,
I'm gonna start that
but I'm gonna go crazy.
I'm gonna box seven days a week.
I'm gonna box.
I think I'm actually
gonna have a fight at 45.
Maribel is one of the four
members of a new office
I've created called
Office of the CEO.
And it basically is
everything is just scaling,
this is just
how I'm rolling now.
Because above and beyond
a Mark Evans or a Brandon,
somebody on a piece of
business, there's so much macro,
especially where I think
this conversation's gonna go.
It's been an unbelievable help.
I'll let Maribel tell you
a little bit about herself.
- [Linda] A little background.
- My name is Maribel Lara.
I've been at Vayner
two and a half years
on the account strategy side.
Most recently, I was VP of U.S.
accounts for ABI but for
the bulk of my time here,
I was predominately on the
PepsiCo portfolio working on
brands like Quaker.
And before being at Vayner,
I worked at Group M where
I worked for a small agency
called M80 that was part of it
that's in social media marketing
and the fun thing about me is
that I didn't work in
marketing at all before that.
So for seven years, I worked
in higher ed administration so
college student services.
I worked at
Cal Poly, San Luis Obispo
in California in
residential life.
My last full time job in higher
ed was at Barnard College where
I was director of
college activities.
So I was at Barnard when
Facebook launched and at the
same time I was considering a
career change and I saw how
quickly Facebook changed the way
that students were communicating
with each other so I was
like there's something to this.
And I had made a decision to go
back to school full time for my
MBA so in focusing in marketing,
wherever I could
I focused on social media.
- That's the crazy part.
It's making, what I'm
about to paint you is,
do that, do pictures,
analyze the data,
do commercials,
analyze the data, correct.
And when all nine pieces are all
collectively less expensive--
- [Linda] Yeah.
- then the three pieces that you
guys have done in your world.
Pay somebody for the
insights, (censored).
Go have (censored)
make an expensive video.
Go have a media agency plan
it that doesn't have your best
interest in mind.
You have three separate
expensive pieces versus nine
pieces that are less
cost across individually and
then that's the game.
- [Linda] Yep.
- [Gary] Do you know how many
people ask me on a daily basis
what would I do at $2,500?
So this happens a million times
a day and my answers are either
A, buy Amazon or
Facebook stock or
B, go by shit
and flip it on eBay,
get to 50,000
and then do something.
- [Linda] Yeah.
- A version of that for
(censored) and it's historical
safety and growth of,
like, there's real stuff.
Great, I'm very excited.
- [Linda] Yeah, good. Okay.
Thank you.
Bye, sweetie.
Give Lizzie my best.
- I will.
- Did you see my
Giants yesterday?
- [Gary] You know what's funny?
I'm in the best mood,--
- [Linda] 'Cause they lost.
- yes, but even better.
I didn't watch any football.
- [Linda] Pittsburgh was good.
- [Maribel] Really?
- I'm not watching any football.
I'm watching
none of the, I'm done.
And so you have to understand,
it's almost as if the Giants and
Dolphins weren't in
the playoffs themselves.
(light music)
Put the 500 fucking hashtags
that matter most in my world,
and have a human every second
fucking clicking them looking at
the accounts, DMing
them and who are the people,
what are the people,
my people, like all of it.
- [Andy] Yeah.
- [Man] How you doing?
- Good, brother.
How are you?
- [Man] Good.
I just want to chat.
- Good. As you should.
- [Man] Yeah, it's been a while.
- Yeah.
Everybody's gonna get
re-calibrated to that new game,
but yeah, man, I mean look,
I think the good news is you've
earned a lot of opportunity.
I'm more than
happy to listen anything
I can bring you value in.
I think the thing
that I want to give you
is the thing you've earned.
Which is flexibility.
I don't know
what else to tell you.
This is all the stuff that we
talked about three years ago,
we're like hey, you know?
You eat shit and it
returns bigger value.
Nobody's gonna lose this game
in a seven or 10 year window.
And it starts manifesting.
What's cooking?
What are you guys jamming on?
Anything good?
All I care about the
world is Facebook commercials.
I genuinely don't
care about anything else.
- [Steve] Don't tell me
you're using the "c"-word.
- Yeah, yeah.
Just so you know, just like the
holding company clarification,
by the way, I'll use any word.
I just want people to
understand what I'm saying.
I need to basically
know what freedom
we have to do that with her.
- Okay.
- [Gary] And I need to get her
in a room and pitch and tell me
where the brand's
sitting and I want to,
what I want to do,
especially at our three levels,
is force them into the system.
- [Steve] Yeah.
We've got her in a good spot.
I think a lot of what they're
struggling with right now
is how--
- It ladders up?
- [DRock] Great.
- Look what's going on now guys!
Alright, boys.
You know what happened?
DRock showed up on video.
I'm gonna reverse it now.
(group laughter)
Watch this dramatic,
DRock is leaving.
Wow!
- To me, that's the ultimate
difference is that we have to
stop using
commercials to tell a story.
It just has to be interesting.
It has to be
something that's relevant.
That's crazy.
That's wild.
Well, for an industry that for
so long influenced
culture so profoundly.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- Right, I mean you
are either the news,
you were Hollywood
or you are a madman.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- There was a power to
create the stuff that influenced
culture and now we live in a
world where everyone is given
the tool to publish and
it's blurry and it's murky,
I find it interesting that
a lot of the ad world
is behind.
A lot of the ad world is the
mom and dad at the party.
Facebook video represents
the opportunity to be more
exploratory and to just try
things and do things because
that's what it is.
It wasn't born
with a set of rules.
It wasn't like you got
it this way and this way and
this way and this way.
There are best practices
that may or may not apply but
I think, first things first,
you have to have a hook.
You have to have that
is an interesting story.
If it's not interesting,
then what's the point?
It has to be.
More than ever 'cause
you're competing with
everything on the internet.
So, it has to be interesting.
It has to be interesting
very quickly and then you as a
creative have to be
willing to optimize.
You have to be
willing to re-cut.
You have to be willing to take
the thing you thought was gonna
interesting and then once
you find out that it wasn't
interesting, 'cause
the market told you so,
you have to be willing to go
well what can
I do with that footage?
Can I DJ it to become,
oh, let's try that.
It's a very different mindset.
It's not going anywhere.
(intense music)
- [Gary] These
headphones are good.
[DRock] Yeah?
- I'd be lying if I didn't say
I'm pretty excited about it.
That was very clear.
There was no string.
I'm still gonna lose them.
But not really.
It looks ridiculous.
- [Marcus] Yeah, they
look a little strange.
That's just on Tyler.
- [Gary] But it's gonna become
social norm
like everything else.
It's really good actually.
I love it more than anything.
I think there's a lot of
other things that happened here.
Very much like I say publicly
for the last decade I believe in
the jockey a lot of times
and not just the horse.
My strategy is reverse
engineering them and always
over-communicating.
I'm sitting in a car right
now with three top talents,
four top talents and the truth
is they all care
about different things.
And they have
different ambitions and
they're all A-players.
But they all
have different lives.
And different
things matter to them.
And so, I try to communicate
with them and I try to create a
world where they feel
comfortable communicating to me
and also I recognize,
one of the top talents,
and I want you to
spell this all out,
one of the top talents, I think,
I'm pretty sure had no kids when
he started with us, now he
has two and that's gonna change
things that matter.
They're young now.
In five years,
'cause I know he'll be here,
you know, he may care about
different things because he may
decide this was the
year he needs to coach.
I don't know but there's only
one strategy with top talent
which is reverse engineer what
they care about and be flexible
to adjust to what
they care about forever.
How many of you are asking
me what I'm gonna do when
I hit a million
followers on Instagram?
Nothing.
Haven't even
been paying attention.
I don't give a fuck.
Sorry.
Just for clarity, I'm very
thankful and grateful but
I'm not gonna like do a
contest to get more followers.
All these people, you know,
I'm massively thankful but
I was grateful at one.
Thanks.
- [Avi] VaynerMedia, 2:30.
- [Woman] Veiny.
- [Avi] Vayner.
- [Joe] Hey Gary?
- [Gary] Yes, sir?
- [Joe] Any chance you
could hit up my boy Bearcrafted?
- [Gary] Bearcrafted?
- [Joe] Bearcrafted.
- [Gary] Yeah, what's his story?
What'd he write?
- [Joe] He's a guy
on my cycling team.
- [Gary] What'd he say there?
- [Joe] Comment on the photo.
Tell Gary I've been a
practitioner for a while but
people like him make me get
through the
harder parts of the--
- [Gary] His name's Cedric?
- [Joe] Cedric, yeah.
- Oh my God, yes.
I love you guys,
congrats, congrats, congrats.
Can't wait to hang.
The amount of people that are
gonna make lots and lots of
money selling stuff on eBay
because of me
this year is insane.
Actually, go look
at this hashtag.
#2017flipchallenge.
No, DRock, I did not want to say
how we've created a challenge
that is going to help thousands
of people make lots of money
that's going to be
significant to them.
Whether to pay off debt or start
their business or deploy against
another underpriced opportunity
like Facebook ads and
Instagram influencers.
No, I don't
want to say anything.
- [DRock] Great.
- [Gary] Right here.
GaryVee, taking profits
and re-investing to buy,
sell higher value
items with wider margins.
Turning books into cars.
- [Marcus] Nice.
- [Gary] No, he's in Ohio.
Canton, Ohio!
Guys, look at this though.
These are like, this
is money that people,
and the big thesis right now
is sell shit that's randomly
sitting in your house.
If you guys understood,
even in their apartments,
that you're actually sitting
with you're sitting with $1900
worth of stuff that's
literally going in the garbage.
It's real.
It's a real thing.
What's up, guys?
Just sitting here.
DRock's filming.
What is this? Episode?
- [DRock] 124.
- [Gary] 124,
Marcus is here, Joe's here,
Bradley's here.
I got Avi to
laugh a bunch today.
Anyway, why I'm really here.
Decided that I want
to post a fan video
on Instagram once a day.
And so, I'll tag their handle.
You'll get hugely blow it up.
We'll get a bunch
of different creative.
See different things.
We just need to figure out how
we're gonna take submissions.
And as always, yeah
okay, good. #FanVee,
Fan-V-e-e.
There we go, that's it then.
That's how we do it, DRock.
Anyway, lot of people do crap
and that's just the way it is
and I won't use it if it's crap.
Won't. But if it's
great, we'll pick it.
So if you want to
make a video, mash-up,
need anything from me,
hit up DRock. (laughs)
Make those videos.
(hip hop music)
Like it's good.
And now we're like triple down
on everything we
can have to support.
Okay.
Basically, it's
taking it from the tippy top,
it's going to be
called Crushed It!
How these 39 people did
it and how you can too, right?
That's kind of energy of it.
Again, from a framework, do we
want to start with their story?
End with their, obviously we
start with me like we always do
and then, you know,
you can decide
that framework but
I think it's either they're
separate in a separate thing and
we do all the platforms.
Like what I would do,
best practices.
But the framework is
no matter what you are,
dancer, singer, painter,
want to sell t-shirts,
I will synthesize
best practices,
opportunities on these platforms
and the state of the union on
those platforms in this book
and then the
stories of those people.
Wait a minute, by the way,
I think there's a great one.
There's a very good one.
A joke I use a lot that we're
definintely gonna use which is
the only person that I
acknowledge in that book besides
my family is Travis
the co-founder of Uber.
So that's a
monster, monster one.
That'll be fun.
Psst.
Yes.
Ready to rock and roll?
One of the vibe
differences is speed.
(DRock laughs)
- [Gary on phone]
Self-awareness is the game.
You know how many people listen
right now that love athletics
and think they have a jumpshot?
- [Nickolas] Gary,
thanks for doing this, man.
- [Gary] Of course.
- [Nickolas] I appreciate it.
I know the schedule has been
kind of crazy
today so it means a lot.
I don't want to waste time,
I want to get right to it.
To be honest with you Gary,
I figured the first question
I'd ask you
would just be a question,
a personal question
if you don't mind.
- [Gary] Sure.
- [Nickolas] About
life 'cause that's what
I'm most interested in.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Nickolas] That's really, just
oftentimes in my hustle
I wait to feel good to do stuff.
I'm a big Tony Robbins fan.
You know Tony, right?
- I do.
- [Nickolas] Okay, sweet.
And his whole thing is like
achievement versus
fulfillment, right?
- Okay.
- [Nickolas] You could achieve
all you want but if you don't
feel good at the end of the
day you end up doing something
stupid like killing yourself
or something even worse.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Nickolas] So my focus,
I'm 21 has been
(inaudible) feeling good.
And I kind of know
that if I don't feel good,
I don't do shit.
- [Gary] I think that's right.
- [Nickolas] Okay, okay, okay.
You think that's right?
- [Gary] I'm a
big believer in that.
- [Nickolas] Yeah?
- [Gary] Which is
why I do so much shit,
'cause I feel so good.
(Nickolas laughs)
I'm being serious.
- [Nickolas] Yeah.
- [Gary] I actually think
that makes a ton of sense.
- [Nickolas] Yeah?
- I think that I didn't do any
school work 'cause it didn't
make me feel good and
I didn't feel good then.
And since I've
been in the real world,
I've been able to focus on the
things that make me happy and
doing real shit.
I couldn't imagine anybody that
doesn't go through some version
of what we're talking about
right now which is feeling good
is the game and the better you
feel the more you have energy,
either you're on
offense or defense.
- [Nickolas] Yes.
- And when
you're not feeling good,
you're on defense which means
you can't do shit 'cause you're
thinking about dumb shit.
- [Nickolas] Okay.
- And you're dwelling and you're
not focused on being on the
offense so I think that makes
a ton of sense so go ahead.
- [Nickolas] So that's a
good point to make.
Essentially, (police siren)
hustling 24/7 isn't
about achieving it's about
making sure that inside you're
heart you're feeling okay.
- [Gary] I couldn't imagine
anybody in the world disagreeing
with doing stuff for
the sake of doing stuff.
Here are the things
that run through my mind.
I would say the primary thing I
ask myself is, "Is this actually
"gonna lead to somebody
showing up at my funeral?"
If you really ask me what
the fuck I do for a living,
it's that I'm trying to create
a legacy because I'm either
A, so egotistical
that I want that.
- Yep.
- Or B, love
human beings so much,
'cause I do and I think that's
why I've popped on social.
- [Nickolas] Yeah.
- So I think a lot of what I
think about is what's the legacy
of this manuever.
- Yeah.
- Like right now, this
is fucking stupid for me.
Doing an interview
with you for 15 minutes,
is fucking ridiculous.
- I love it, I love it.
- It makes no God damn sense but
I'm feeling pretty good about
the odds of maybe this leading
to you showing up to my funeral.
That's how I think about stuff,
so I'm very big
on what it is impact,
how does it impact me
and more importantly the other
person in the narrative that I
care about which is I think
I was gifted with
some real crazy shit.
(hip hop music)
- Enough talent to be able to do
my thing for me and still have
so much left
over to give so much.
- To give, yeah, yeah.
- That to me is crazy.
I wish people understood.
I wish people understood what I
would look like from a business
success standpoint if I actually
took all this
energy and made it selfish.
It'd be over already.
- [Nickolas] It'd be game over.
- Over!
I think my thing is very simple.
There's never been a day in my
life where I've done something
with the wrong intent.
- [Nickolas] I love that.
- [Gary] I want to win and I
want other people to win too.
- [Nickolas] So long
as the intent's right,
you kind of just
roll with whatever.
- [Gary] 100%.
I want to build the
biggest building in town.
- [Nickolas] Yeah.
- The way I want to do that
is by building
the biggest building.
- [Nickolas] Not tearing
other people's shit down.
- That's it.
I say it all the time 'cause
it's the thing that I've seen
that separates me which is a lot
of people that are as hungry and
as ambitious as I am
are insecure in reality.
- [Nickolas] Yep.
- And I'm just not and of
course I have insecurities.
For example, I wasn't a
1000% secure in getting all the
cutest girls I ever saw and
that wasn't my strength.
- [Nickolas] Yep.
- But when it comes to business,
when it comes to people
behavior, I just
got it like that.
- [Nickolas] You just...
- Thank you, my man.
- 'Preciate it.
- Thank you.
DRock's gonna
take over from here.
- [Nickolas] Okay.
Thanks for everything.
Alright, cheers, brother.
- So one of the great perks of
selling your company
to me is court side seats.
I got a big discount in buying
PureWow by offering these
court side seats.
- That's right.
- What up, guys?
Just creating some
clarity to what #FanVee is.
It's people who create
mash-ups of video content.
The stuff that
DRock and Other Tyler make
and then we put it out.
So if you want showcase
your editing and video skills,
you can take any clips that you
want from my stuff and mash them
together, any audio from a
podcast and mash them together.
You can even once in a while hit
me up and I'll do some original
to the screen video and send it
to you if you kind of want to
get fancy but you might
have to wait 'cause I'm,
you know, it gets busy
a little bit but anyway,
that's a little clarification
to what #FanVee is.
I'm gonna be showcasing on
my page videos from fans that
mash-up my content,
the stuff that I would
share to the audience.
Kind of like the episode 101.
The classic DailyVee which was
done by a fan from Portugal.
That kind of
stuff for Instagram.
One minute video mash-ups.
- [Nickolas] Yeah.